this episode is brought to you by the
music for scientists album
now available on all streaming services
[Music]
when it comes to making more of
themselves single-celled eukaryotes
or protists have a few options they can
go the asexual reproduction route
dividing and making nearly exact copies
of themselves
and this is a pretty nice way of life
the euglenoids have taken
to it so strongly that they've never
been observed reproducing
any other way i mean think of the
advantages
you don't have to waste time trying to
find a mate and when the process is done
the end result is more of yourself
now that might sound narcissistic but
when it comes to survival it's also
pragmatic if your genes work
why not just make more of them but the
world
is always changing and testing the
organisms within it
temperatures can become uncomfortable
nutrients can become
scarce and enemies can become plentiful
adapting to these changing conditions
requires change in the
organism and its progeny
that change can come about in many
different ways and manifest in many
different
forms but one of the tried and true
methods
is sexual reproduction the principle
seems straightforward enough
whether you're talking about protists or
plants or people
you take two parents mix and match their
genes and produce a set of offspring
with the hopes
that they will better survive the
hardships of both the present
and the future of course in practice
sexual reproduction takes on many
different forms
some of which we've documented and
discussed already on this channel
today we're going to focus on one
particular method of ciliate
reproduction
my personal favorite conjugation
we've actually shown ciliates like these
midcoitus before
sometimes they seem to be frantically
chasing each other like these two
are and sometimes they're more chill
like two blobs that are just very
very close to explain what makes this
specifically conjugation
we need to first take a moment to
explain a different kind of sexual
reproduction
for some protists like chlamydomonas
sexual reproduction
is a fusion of two gamete cells
it will spend much of its life as an
asexual cell
reproducing through binary fission or
just
splitting in two but when the
environment gets tough
it will turn into a gamete that belongs
in one of two mating types when a gamete
finds its opposite mating type the two
fuse
to create a zygote that then divides to
create the progeny
conjugation in contrast is not the
fusion
of two gamete cells it is the fusion of
gametic
nuclei
what is that
well when you watch too silly it's
mid-conjugation you are watching
two individuals that have fused together
but it's a temporary connection forged
by a mutual desire
for the others nuclei
now ciliates have two different kinds of
nuclei the macronucleus
and the micronucleus the macronucleus
works like
our own housing the genetic template
that gets transcribed and translated
into the molecules the organism needs
for its daily life
but in conjugation the micronucleus
becomes the dominant player
dividing through meiosis to create a
series of
pro-nuclei that contain a single set
of the organism's genetic material
though all but
one of the pro-nuclei will get promptly
destroyed
the one that remains divides by mitosis
so that the organism now has two
identical copies
of the pro-nuclei one for itself and one
for its partner in the meantime their
original macronucleus will
fall apart which would normally be
catastrophic but in this case
it is deliberate the two ciliates will
then exchange
one of their pronuclei with the other
through their connected
mouths and each will fuse their
pronucleus with their partners to create
a zygotic nucleus
[Music]
this new nucleus combines and rearranges
the genetic material inherited from both
parents
replacing the old macronucleus
with this new remixed version
so instead of having sex and producing
offspring these two ciliates have sex
and become the offspring they are both
genetically different after the
conjugation
than they were before when they're done
the conjugates
separate and to pass those new genes
onto another generation the organisms
will have to eventually
divide producing daughter cells that now
carry their own copies of this
new nucleus so
what sets the mood for conjugation
well it can be a few things for
paramecium tetrarelia
it can be a matter of age scientists
have documented that paramecium
tetrarelia can only survive
around 200 rounds of asexual
reproduction
unless it undergoes self-fertilization
or
conjugation to patch up the genetic
damage that can accumulate over multiple
rounds of division
scientists have also observed that a
lack of nutrients can
set other organisms off to conjugate but
of course
environmental or aging considerations
aside
the most vital step is just finding a
partner
think of how difficult this must be for
microbes they've got to navigate a world
of debris and predators without sound or
sight or any of the large-scale mating
displays you often find in the macro
world
and even if you do find someone to mate
with they might be a bit occupied
like these two hypertric ciliates that
are trying so hard
to rudely interrupt a couple that is
already
mid conjugation they are expending so
much effort though the solution to their
predicament
seems so obvious they should just
channel that energy
into conjugating with each other
so why are they so preoccupied with a
couple that's already taken
well for one possible answer let's look
at a different ciliate
the blepharisma within a few hours of
being starved
sexually mature blepharisma will pair up
and begin
conjugation but the process is more than
just stumbling around the micro cosmos
blepharisma come in two mating types
called mating type 1 and mating type 2
which will only mate with the opposite
type and to find their partners
blepharisma rely
on chemical signals when type 1
blepharism
are starved they begin to secrete a
chemical called gammon
1 which alerts any nearby type 2
blepharisma to the fact that there are
some
type ones waiting around and interested
the type 2 cells transform and release a
chemical called yes
gammon 2 which then finds its way to the
type 1 cells
these gammons do more than help the
different mating types find each other
they
act upon them to get them ready for
conjugation
kind of like microscopic flirting with a
hidden chemical language
for our poor unloved hypotric ciliates
what's likely happened is that they are
the same mating type as each other
drawn to the same location because of
the secretions
of one of the conjugating pair but alas
they both showed up too late to the
party and they've remained
too chemically preoccupied with the
object of their conjugational affections
to divert their attentions to each other
so while conjugation may be advantageous
for the species
it doesn't always work out so well for
the individuals
but as always with biology the
underlying mechanisms are often
more mysterious than the simple image we
originally lay out
blepharisma and other ciliates with
mating types can sometimes
spontaneously switch their mating type
though we don't fully understand
how or why this happens this
is but one moment in these hypotrics
attempt at conjugation
who knows what the next one will look
like
and as for the conjugating pair well we
wish them
and their progeny the best because when
the camera is gone
and the day is done these two organisms
may never see each other again but
they've shared
this moment and their nuclei
and they've made the microcosmos all the
richer for it
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us patrick olsen
is a composer musician and science
publisher who recently released his
album
music for scientists an album made in
tribute to those
that have dedicated their lives to
science-driven work
and the music itself is inspired by the
beauty of science and the knowableness
of the universe one track on the album
is called
the idea the song touches on how
difficult it is to form
correct ideas and how for every right
answer
there are an infinite number of wrong
ones the music video for that track was
produced with the help of artist
john todd and the team over at thought
cafe and it's a creative hybrid of
analog
painting and artificial intelligence if
you think that sounds like something you
might enjoy click the link in the
description to see the video or
stream the music on all major music
services
all of the people whose names are on the
screen right now
they are our patreon patrons they are
the people who make this show
possible so if you like what we do these
are the people to thank
and i know that all of us on the micro
cosmos team are deeply deeply grateful
to them
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you